right so I I think I think them doing
something that is kind of the the
parallel to to Elder scows is is super
exciting for a lot of people in the
pillars Universe too yeah that part yeah
absolutely exactly the pillars Universe
which a lot of people love those games
as well um and then you look at um you
look at hellblade and that last look at
hellblade we finally got a look at some
combat yes I wasn't as impressed with it
as I hoped I would be because it's it
still felt heavy still felt like it was
going to be like very like you know
you're looking at your you look at your
opponent you can tell when they're going
to swing up you can tell when they're
going to swing down it's more about
parrying and blocking getting out of the
way it didn't feel like it was a smooth
sort of combat um inter because it feels
like the weapons are heavy right so it's
not just talk about the weight more like
the weight of it like the weight of it
doesn't doesn't lend itself to this very
sort of smooth combat experiences